baja california se une desde luego
también a esta jornada electoral 2021 en
unos comicios que llaman la atención no
solamente de la prensa a nivel nacional
sino a nivel internacional ya que se
empata por primera vez en la historia en
baja california la elección para decidir
quién será el próximo gobernador o
gobernadora así como las alcaldías y
también las diputaciones locales y
nacionales en medio de estas elecciones
llamadas intermedias que como lo hemos
estado comentando son importantes pues
baja california busca luchar contra un
enemigo que siempre ha estado presente
el abstencionismo y es que los datos más
recientes de las últimas elecciones en
el 2019 hablan de hasta un 70 por ciento
de personas que no acudieron a emitir su
voto bien pues la lucha será ahora
precisamente tratar de acaparar a este
electorado ya que estas personas lleguen
a las urnas que precisamente las tenemos
ahorita en pantalla para emitir su voto
una jornada que se ha visto empañada por
algunos incidentes violentos como
precisamente en la capital del estado
de urnas desde temprano también el
ataque a balazos al inmueble a las
oficinas del partido morena el partido
que se encuentra en el poder a nivel
nacional pero no sólo eso en otro
municipio en rosarito un ex presidente
municipal fue detenido momentáneamente
porque se la acusó de tener propaganda
política en su vehículo sin embargo
minutos más tarde se confirmó que la
información era negativa y bueno se le
dejó ir sin ningún problema aquí en
tijuana aquí en tijuana desde donde nos
encontramos reportando han ocurrido
algunos hechos violentos y preocupantes
y es que por la mañana fueron lanzadas
dos cabezas humanas en bolsas de
plástico así como restos también manos a
casillas del este de la ciudad lo que
provocó que la de la apertura de estas
casillas buenos se retrasará en lo que
la policía hacía las diligencias para
tratar de investigar qué era lo que
había ocurrido algunos empujones algunos
conatos de violencia que han acontecido
y bueno la policía y la guardia nacional
ha tenido que intervenir
evitar que esto se salga de las manos y
que las elecciones se sigan
desarrollando como debe de ser en medio
de un ambiente de calma es importante
mencionar que en baja california se
instalaron un promedio de cuatro mil
casillas cerca de 33.000 personas 33 mil
ciudadanos fungieron como funcionarios
de casilla apoyando precisamente toda
esta contienda y bueno para tratar de
dar agilidad a los cerca de 2.9 millones
de personas que están en el padrón
electoral de baja california y que
podrían y que deberían mejor dicho
también emitir su voto este es el
panorama desde tijuana baja california
méxico